[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je les connais je voudrais tellement
qu'elle sache noire
emmenez-moi une autre s'il te plaît mais
moi je mets fort fort
[Musique]
première fois
oui
[Applaudissements]
c'est combien de disques vendu Jeanne
Mas je sais même pas je crois qu'on
essaie de trouver nous on a un chiffre
on a plus de 3 millions de disques pour
un écoute ça doit être ça plus de 3
millions c'est quoi le plus gros tube
dans tout ce qu'on a entendu là
ça a été toute première fois et puis par
la suite Johnny en rouge et noir ou tous
ces suivis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors attends on va regarder un petit
Manito récap et après je vous promets
quoi à parler du bouquin mais est-ce que
après est-ce qu'après vous pourrez me
faire une petite chorégraphie parce que
j'aimerais savoir en fait évidemment les
chansons qui écrivaient tout je le sais
le look ça c'était vous mais les
chorégraphies qui étaient tellement
marquées dans la regarder sur internet
bouger saccadé c'était vous ça vous
pouvez m'en faire une petite
chanson parce que vous êtes chez vous
d'accord alors
[Musique]
pour la toute première fois elle est
l'invité exceptionnelle de TPMP people
Jeanne Mas cette chanteuse originaire
d'Alicante a conquis le public français
dans les années 80
[Musique]
trois Victoires de la Musique trois
Olympias et plusieurs fois en tête des
hit parade 40 ans après les tubes de la
star font toujours autant danser en
soirée Jeanne Mas c'est vraiment mon
idole vous connaissez forcément Johnny
Johnny sauvez-moi en rouge et noir rouge
et noir
succès qui font de Jeanne Mas une
artiste incontournable si elle n'en a
jamais terminé avec la musique
aujourd'hui Jeanne Mas a pris un peu de
recul sur cet univers pas toujours
facile sa nouvelle vie son combat ses
futurs projets ce soir Jeanne Mas nous
révèle tout dans TPMP people
James énorme énorme énorme star c'est
vrai que vous avez refusé le tube
[Musique]
en fait c'était très très similaire à
Johnny Johnny et j'avais envie d'évoluer
en fait
d'un côté j'ai très bien fait puisque
c'est Fanny on a fait un tube et que moi
je suis arrivée avec en rouge et noir
oui mais Stéphanie vous vous en auriez
fait un tube mondial
ça va être SLAs qu'on va faire
maintenant c'est incroyable ce que je
pensais pas vous accepteriez
on va mettre la musique
[Applaudissements]
comme ça
[Musique]
au début
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chaussures long de nuit
[Applaudissements]
et l'âme sans faire sans être équilibre
ça se dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous dire ah si la grande
faucheuse venez m'emmener maintenant là
d'un coup tu es prêt je voudrais même
pas elle est là
je voulais pas venir j'étais bloquée
à cause de toutes ces histoires de vol
de covid de machin
oui
j'ai quand même je suis quand même venue
à cette avec
en plus je pense que tu as connu ça
Laurent tu as toujours un attaché de
presse qui dit alors quand la star vient
tu lui parles un peu pas trop de sais-tu
on danse pas on chante pas il déteste ça
machin et quand tu as la star en plateau
est charmante un artiste reste à la
porte
privé
vous êtes heureuse en ce moment tout va
bien
et j'ai une vie privée
oui je pense que ça va vous savez mon
psy que je vois une fois tous les 15
jours maintenant me disait quand
j'arrive il me dit mets-moi une note sur
10 comme ça hop sans réfléchir mets-moi
une note sur 10 comme ça à ta vie tu as
ta vie privée ton bonheur ou matériaux
mon but n'est pas d'être heureuse mon
but c'est d'accomplir des choses dans ma
vie je ne suis pas venu sur terre pour
être heureux je suis venu pour voilà
j'ai des missions et voilà hein c'est
compliqué je reviendrai pour ça
ma prochaine mission et bien justement
j'attends que mes guides spirituels me
poussent mais je pense que c'est me
préoccuper plus des autres et de la
planète c'est de la planète c'est vous
qui c'est pour ça que j'écris un livre
sur le véganisme parce qu'en fait là je
suis sérieux on vous entendez des fois
il y a des gens qui va vous entendez
quelque chose qui vous pousse à réaliser
une mission je ressens les choses bien
sûr bien sûr en fait il faut écouter son
moi il faut écouter son intérieur parce
qu'on a tous des guides spirituels qui
nous aident à accomplir nos missions sur
terre sauf que on vit avec un ego
tellement puissant qu'on l'oublie en
fait que nous avons cette mission donc
ce qui se passe c'est que justement
quand on a raté sa vie et bien on
revient ça s'appelle karma mais non ça
ne te parle pas Mathieu
j'ai pas fait toujours les bons choix
donc c'est pas la bonne c'est pas j'ai
faut que je change de personnes qui me
parle
déjà oui vous pouvez changer vos guides
spirituels un petit peu mais pas c'est
pas aussi simple que ça en fait écouter
sa voix c'est c'est mettre en avant les
autres avant de avant soi-même ah ça va
être difficile pour Mathieu ça va être
ça d'accord donc générosité bah oui
compassion générosité a avancer exact
avec l'amour inconditionnels
je suis très sérieux est-ce que par
exemple avant de faire une émission de
télévision avant d'aller quelque part
vous ressentez des choses vous vous
dites là non c'est pas bon pour moi
c'est bon pour moi je je vous avais des
enfin voilà par exemple alors moi je
suis très sensible aux énergies des
autres c'est à dire que je sens quand
quelqu'un n'est pas bon et en fait je
reste avec une sensation très très
mauvaise et je sais qu'en fait cette
personne m'a transmis des énergies
négatives
est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un ici qui vous
transmet un truc négatif il y a trop
d'énergie autour de moi pour comprendre
ce qui se passe et moi vous avez sorti
du positif bah oui que du positif
[Applaudissements]
la même question si elle arrivait à
percevoir comme ça en faisant un tour de
taille c'est la percevoir les gens qui
étaient bons parents je trouvais ça
intéressant
je ne suis pas médium mais je suis
sensitive et on l'est tous on est tous
plus ou moins c'est juste est-ce qu'on
développe cette cette opportunité qu'on
a de recevoir les autres ou pas mais en
fait ce que je disais tout à l'heure
c'est qu'on vit tellement avec notre ego
qu'en fait c'est l'ego qu'on met en
avant et c'est ça qu'on devrait
commencer à retirer pour vivre mieux et
quand on a participé à la même émission
tous les deux ben je prétends quand on
sait bien senti tout à fait mais est-ce
que c'est ça ce qu'on appelle HPI ou pas
du tout je sais pas
ressentir les choses avec beaucoup
d'émotions
ça c'est le quotient intellectuel HP
donc ça a rien à voir là c'est plus sur
c'est plus le rituel c'est plus
spirituel c'est savoir qu'en fait dans
un nous sommes deux il y a le corps
qu'on véhicule et puis nous sommes nous
sommes avant toute chose sauf une âme en
fait mais bon là si vous
savez qui paraît que certains nages que
vous n'avez pas on a le physique de qui
on est et vous êtes magnifique
c'est quelque chose que vous avez c'est
quelque chose que vous avez étudié ou
que vous avez ou c'est ou c'est un
cheminement personnel vraiment où c'est
vous appartenez à un groupe peut-être
une religion ou alors on appartient tous
à un groupe spirituel c'est vrai que moi
il y a quelques années je ressentais des
choses que je ne comprenais pas donc
j'ai fait une thérapie spirituelle c'est
à dire j'ai voulu comprendre pourquoi je
m'étais réincarné pourquoi je crois en
la réincarnation mais je crois non mais
une fois qu'on une fois qu'on rentre
dans tout ça ça donne un sens à la vie
ça donne un sens à tout ce qu'on fait ça
donne un sens et je finis c'est en fait
oui je j'ai totalement tellement changé
et j'ai surtout changé ma vision des
autres c'est à dire que je regarde les
autres sans aucun jugement mais vous
êtes réincarné c'est-à-dire que vous
savez qui vous étiez avant oui j'étais
une multitude qui explique une multitude
qu'est-ce que c'est une multitude bah
c'est à dire qu'en fait on n'a pas vécu
une seule vie auparavant on en a vécu
des centaines donc on arrive avec des
centaines et voir pour certains des
milliers de personnalités et de vie
c'est ce qui permet de comprendre
pourquoi je change souvent la couleur de
mes cheveux pourquoi je change souvent
mes looks pourquoi est-ce que j'adore
déménager pourquoi tout ça et en fait
les explications sont venues parce que
je ne suis pas un je suis une multitude
de mots est-ce que quelque chose que que
après tout ça justement dans votre
carrière que vous n'auriez pas fait ou
pas refait peut-être avec du recul oui
bien sûr mais je ne le savais pas
puisque même si je refaisais cette vie
en décidant de me réincarner de revivre
cette vie je referai exactement les
mêmes choses parce que je n'ai pas accès
aux connaissances
et c'est passionnant tout ça vous restez
avec tout parce que j'ai parlé de chance
pas de bol
depuis 10 ans à peu près oh ouais bien
plus j'étais végétarienne avant j'ai
commencé à être végétariens à l'âge de
17 ans quand j'ai quitté la maison de
mes parents vous êtes particulière quand
même mais vous restez bien avec nous
dans un instant plus sur un débat qui va
vous passionné c'est sur justement
l'écologie les jets vous apprenez des
jets bah non non c'est génial ah bon ben
vous pourrez pas je marche en plus
cet été pour pas reprendre l'avion non
mais moi je suis très préoccupée par la
planète et je l'adore cette planète donc
je fais tout pour la préserver mais je
peux vous demander
vous vivez où en France en France
qu'importe où j'habite puisque j'habite
sur terre vous avez été sur terre oui je
n'ai pas la sensation de d'appartenir à
un pays à quoi que ce soit je vous avais
quand même une propriété
ouais mais dans la zone A dans ces
cas-là
on revient dans un instant bien sûr avec
Jeanne Mas au Maroc et tous les secrets
sur la reine à tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci d'être avec le TPMP Jeanne Mas
c'est notre invité
et si vous venez de nous rejoindre elle
nous parle elle nous dit tout elle danse
elle chante elle est charmante
c'est là qu'on connaît les vrais
artistes qui sont toujours charmants
quand il s'agit de voilà de donner on va
parler dans un instant de l'écologie je
suis très important pour vous on va
parler des jets privés de tout ce qui se
passe autour du scandale et on a
quelqu'un qui a été courageux de venir
qui viendra un instant qui s'appelle
Omar Harfouche qui avait fait la Ferme
Célébrité donc on le connait un petit
peu pour ça voilà il a il a un jet il
s'en sert à 22 fois par an pour faire
Paris Nice lui il dit voilà je le prends
en gros et je vous emmerde il fallait
gagner de l'argent donc voilà on pourra
en parler ensemble mais c'est un garçon
charmant au demeurant oh oui depuis
qu'il m'invite dans son jet mais mais
sinon non non pas du tout et là je veux
dire un petit mot comme parce qu'il y a
un bouquin c'est très important ça
s'appelle génération vegan que vous avez
sorti vous savez des années que vous
êtes végan mais pourquoi le bouquin
maintenant c'est le troisième que je
sors j'avais sorti ma vie est une pomme
Hugo végan en herbe et puis là j'ai
voulu continuer et puis cette fois-ci
expliquez vraiment les fondements mais
surtout répondre aux questions qu'on se
pose est-ce qu'on a des carences mais si
les animaux on ne les tue pas qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont devenir est-ce que les
plantes souffrent et en fait je réponds
à toutes ces questions c'est très simple
c'est très en fait je ne juge pas en
fait j'explique un petit peu pourquoi
moi je suis devenue végane et pourquoi
d'autres oui il y a énormément de
témoignages de gens qui ont changé leur
vie leur vie à été totalement changé et
leur santé surtout grâce aux véganisme
et en fait voilà c'est juste guider
comme ça ah bon parce qu'il y a un dog
sur Netflix notamment qui a montré des
gros bodybuilders notamment mangent
beaucoup de légumes à protéines dans les
légumes il faut arrêter de penser mais
ça c'était et je suis en train de brisé
par le lobby vegan sur portage je l'ai
vu moi aussi j'étais convaincu
d'ailleurs Mathieu c'est marrant parce
que quand je l'ai vu après pendant 15
jours j'ai arrêté de manger de la viande
et malheureusement mon corps s'est
dégradé je dois le dire honnêtement mon
corps s'est dégradé moi qui fait
beaucoup de musculation j'ai vu mes
muscles fondre et j'ai dû reprendre une
alimentation carnivore Mathieu je suis
désolé
en revanche sur le remplacer par par les
légumes et tout par exemple mon ventre
les steaks de soja le soja il y a pas
plus désastreux pour les cultures en eau
et en tout que le soja donc remplacer un
problème par un autre je suis pas sûr
que ce soit bien alors je veux répondre
aux questions la première est qu'on ne
on élimine pas la viande les protéines
animales sans remplacer avec des
protéines végétales et ce que font les
grands athlètes aujourd'hui dont Serena
Williams l'exemple type d'une végan
c'est on remplace par le rise and beans
et en fait c'est ce que vous avez fait
malheureusement tel apport de glucides
parce que dans les protéines végétales
il y a aussi beaucoup de glucides par
rapport aux viandes maigre et donc du
coup naturellement le muscle reste un
peu mais il y a du gras désolé c'est
technique mais c'est un petit peu
technique un petit peu de temps mais de
toute façon c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on
peut passer par les protéines végétales
quant au soja il faut savoir que 90% de
la production mondiale du soja va à
l'élevage donc quand vous mangez un
steak vous mangez du soja quoi qu'il en
soit parce que ça a été assimilé par
on va arrêter